so I'm Franciscan boy and today I'm
gonna be talking about polymer gopher
that's a very awesome name it's
basically about building web apps on App
Engine with Poe with both go and polymer
so a little bit of myself I'm a
developer advocate for the Google cloud
platform but I joined Google to be well
I joined the developer relations team to
work with the go team specifically I'm a
gopher I write go all the time except
when I have to write JavaScript like
today and I hit it myself a little bit
and I'm not a foreign engineer really at
all and I think that this is an
important point because you will see
that the app that I'm gonna build looks
good which is surprising and that's
because polymer helps you do these kind
of things really easily okay so the the
talk is gonna be pretty much structured
at the beginning and then not at all so
first I will do a little bit of an
introduction to what is App Engine we're
gonna be building everything on that
technology so what is App Engine why why
should I use it then I will explain the
app that we're gonna build which is
called polymer gopher and finally I will
actually life code it let's see if we
have time and let's see if I remember
how to do it and finally at the end
there will be pizza and Q&A there's
already pizza and if you have questions
you can also ask them so cool ok so how
many of you know Angry Birds cool ok
that's completely relate it's related to
the topic so Angry Birds is a game about
girl birds that are not happy and it's a
huge success and they have one thing
which is they have these weekly
tournaments every Monday there's a new
tournament that starts and a bunch of
people like hundreds of thousands maybe
millions of people connect to try to win
those tournaments so they have Monday
parts bursts these what their traffic
looks like pretty much so you can see
it's very very calm and then on Mondays
it goes up and the unit is is in
unicorns because that data is
confidential so I cannot share it but
you can see the vis how much it
increases all of a sudden you're gonna
need a huge huge amount of machines to
handle that traffic now if you were
using your machines or if you if you
were using compute engine for instance
where you decide how many studies you
have how many instances you should have
well enough to handle that peak and a
little bit more just in case right so
most of the time more than half of your
machines could be idle you couldn't be
it couldn't do anything so to do that
what they use is App Engine they solve
that problem with App Engine so App
Engine basically what it is it's it's a
place to run your apps which is a
sandbox environment so there's a lot of
things that you can do there's
constraints such as you cannot run any
language that you want we're actually
moving that with managed VMs but today
I'm gonna be talking about only App
Engine so with App Engine you can use
only go Python Java and PHP and you can
install third-party libraries other than
the ones that come with the languages in
the language itself so if you want to do
image processing and you want to use
some C++ library Benji is not really for
you that's not gonna work
again with managed VMs that won't be
solved in exchange of those constraints
what you get is something that will
scale
directly what with your code so with
your traffic so if you have a peak like
they had that's gonna work you don't
have to care about it it would just work
now if you don't have any traffic the
good thing is that you won't have an
instance and you won't play anything so
everything that I build myself I build
it on App Engine form with my personal
account I don't have billing activated
with my personal account and I have
never paid so there's the free tier is
actually pretty high so this is great
for me for personal development is great
and if it turns out to be super
successful
well that will still work ok so this is
pretty much so on the bottom side you
can see the blue line that's a number of
instances that that start when the peak
arrives you can see that it's
way too much and it's way too many but
that's just because we're actually ready
for a bigger peak so if the traffic peak
at the traffic peak was not that bad Tim
times more we could still handle that
but since most of those instances that
started were not actually used by your
traffic you see the the green line there
that's the line that's the actual build
the number of hours there the number of
instance hours that will actually build
so you get a lot of scalability without
not really paying for it so works very
well ok so if you have one instance and
you have one database that works you
have one 100 instances in one database
well if you have 1 million instances in
one database that's gonna be a problem
so how about how does that scale well
you can have multiple instances for the
database and handle duplication and so
on or you could also do something else
like using a non relational database
that is fully managed and you don't have
to care about anything in there and
that's exactly what datastore is data
stories are not relational database so
if you've used MongoDB if things like
that it's pretty pretty much the same
and it also got all the scales with a
mate's meaning that you don't have to
choose an initial size and then upgrade
to another size it would just keep on
growing with your data it's fully
managed so it doesn't go down basically
and they use it like we did Angry Birds
they use it pretty much for everything
they just store everything there and
that's what we will use today in our app
something important about datastore is
that it's actually powered by two
technologies that we created at Google
BigTable that powers things like Gmail
for instance so it's pretty powerful
that scales really well and then there
is another thing called mega store and
mega store will replicate all of your
data across multiple data centers in
different regions so if we lose one
whole data center you will not lose a
single byte so that's pretty useful and
this this is the the full schema now and
I'm gonna get into much detail but all
of those things are actually built on
appengine completely on appengine
everything works on appengine and you
see there's two
goes for a pension that's the old logo
for App Engine which i think is better
than the new one but if you have all of
those two that's actually two different
modules in App Engine you can have
multiple modules that are independent
types of servers which all belong to the
same app and the good thing about this
is that you can you can write them in
different languages so you could have
one in Java another one in go and I
wanted Python and so on so that could be
pretty useful and we're gonna also use
that today okay now the question how
many developers do you think that work
in this project right now on Angry Birds
27 one yeah
there is one developer that manages new
features and they are not adding many
and bugs and they don't have many and
then everything else all DevOps develops
I'm making sure that the app stays up
that's on us so that's pretty good yeah
they're basically now they're doing all
the things rather than maintaining
rather than making sure that Angry Birds
doesn't go down what they do is making
new games to try to be even richer okay
so now polymer gopher which is gonna be
almost as successful as Angry Birds
hopefully its app engine app and we're
gonna use modules the the front end
module is gonna be ringing polymer which
is not a language so it's actually HTML
CSS and JavaScript and that's none of
the languages that I said that the app
engine support but we're actually
cheating because that those are
completely static so we're gonna be
serving static files
that's everything we're going to be
doing with the front end and then the
back end is the one that is gonna be
doing things and that's raining go
completely and we're gonna store all the
data that we have in the data store and
we're going to communicate with club
endpoints I was playing I will spin what
Cloud endpoints is in a minute we're
going to be building this beautiful app
that is actually live right now so you
can see let's make it bigger you can
create a new node and see
Briony see there your is amazing and we
can find a logo gopher gopher logo no
not that one
gopher golden logo we're gonna get one
image the image gonna get that super
long thing gonna put it here if you were
building a good app that's not the best
way of I think I'm a touch I know and I
just created and pull my god there you
go and now we have Brian they're saying
that go is amazing then you can say oh
yeah I love that comment and you can go
back here and remove it it will
disappear and if you refresh you still
get the same things because everything
is backed up in the data store so we're
gonna be building this from scratch
today except for the front end the front
end is actually not that hard and all
the code will be open source
soon I will send it for review today and
some days should be open source okay
what else
so these architecture but we try to full
screen there you go so this is the
architecture of what we're gonna be
building we're gonna have all the data
is going to be storing the data store
our back-end will access it and provide
a REST API to the front end and the
front end and the back end will be
connected through the REST API that it's
actually created with Cloud endpoints
and Cloud endpoints is a really cool
thing because basically it allows you to
generate REST API is with discovery
documents and a discovery document for a
REST API is basically just a description
and jason of what your api can do and
with that we can actually generate code
so if you if you have a description I
just said the word and I forgot it
discovery document if you have a
discovery document there's a lot of
tools that will generate code for you so
with the clips for instance you can auto
generate code in Java so you can build
your your Android apps easily for our
case it would
javascript libraries for us so we don't
have to care about exactly how to do the
course everything which has been also
generated and also works with iOS so
yeah words for path Java and Python and
I'd actually were to make sure that it
actually works in go now so that's
something slightly new and it generates
code for iOS Android web apps but it's
completely technology independent so if
you want to generate code for other
languages it's actually easy you just
have to pass a JSON and figure out how
to generate that code so how many of you
have to use polymer before ok not so
many ok how many of you consider they'll
sell themselves as back-end engineers
okay that explains that so with polymer
the thing that we're trying to solve is
that we're using web components is
actually really hard there's a lot of
ways of solving that problem but so far
all the solutions that I've used so far
we're not really suitable for me because
there was a problem which is your CSS if
you change something in your CSS for one
it will actually change that properly
for all the elements and so on polymer
solves that form using one thing that's
called a shadow Dom just 9 they're gonna
get into much detail but basically it's
something slightly new that helps you
have completely independent pieces of
HTML they're gonna be composing the good
thing about this is that it helps you
reuse components so easily that we
actually use that to provide components
to write with material design a material
design is how Google is designing the
new products so that's actually we go
back to these page this thing that you
can see that that beautiful effect and
how these words and so on all of this is
is actually material design and the cool
thing is these actually just like maybe
six lines of HTML to generate this
beautiful template and I don't know if
you saw before but there's that text
going up that's cool I don't know how to
do
that so oh I broke that again
so yeah let's code first of all how many
of you have written go before I let's do
a question little side around actually
how many of you have not written go
before okay this should be okay it's
gonna be if there if it's not if there's
something you don't understand just ask
questions go is very easy to read that's
one of the best things that go has but
if there's something that is not clear
and I don't explain it just interrupt me
I'm happy to explain cool so we're gonna
start during the back end and the back
end has two pieces so there's two files
one is what we call the abdomen the add
the jammer is basically just describing
what this is and I'm saying oh this is
an application and this is the
application the the IV so this is a
project ID that I got when I created an
app engine app these are given I agree
that you choose a project creation I'm
gonna say that this is the mod model
default because you're gonna have to
default on the front-end this is the
version 1 runtime one go and API version
go on so this just saying these that go
App Engine app that's everything and
then we have handlers so handlers we're
going to be matching different paths to
different handlers so we could have
static files we can have Python we can
have whatever won't to have this
specific keyword says that anything so
any request will be redirected to be
handled by the go up so what we what
were you writing and we say secure
always so everything will be always
redirected to HTTPS which is always
better cool so on the other side that's
everything we have and this is an app
engine app now this one doesn't do
anything so far so we're going to do is
we create an app engine app that
actually does something that just prints
hello world to start with with that with
something
you will see that when I save new things
will appear on the top that's those are
the import statements and there's a tool
going import that will do that for me so
I don't have to remember to put them on
and off and so on okay so the first
thing that I have to do is to say how do
I handle my requests and to do that I
will use the funk in it the folk in it
is a function that is executed at the
beginning of the program before main so
this between the viable declarations and
the main function there's init that come
like that is executed so we're gonna say
I want to handle anything that matches
that your that path so everything starts
with the slash so everything I want to
handle that with my handler cool and
what is a handler well HTTP so a handler
is something that looks like this so
actually I know my relatives
it's an HTTP handler is a function that
receives two parameters the first one is
a response writer on which I can I can
write things and the second one it's the
pointer to the HTTP request so you have
an HTTP request that contains all the
parameters cookies and so on and the
response writer you can set the headers
and then write things into it cool so
what I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna call
println hello and now the thing is that
if I print it and not printing anywhere
I'm just printing it probably - no ER
so what I want to do is I want to print
to the output and the Apple is W and for
that there's actually F print element so
F println if you've done some UNIX F
print actually writes to a file
descriptor and go it writes to something
that we call writer which response
writer is a writer so you can run into
it cool so this is a complete App Engine
app let's try so I'm going to go observe
stay
zero da da mo now steps your own so go
up will run this locally and we'll start
my localhost:8080
so it would say it's okay I'm ready I'm
running it compiled all the code it
didn't the cool compile the code
compiled so it didn't complain and now
we can open that see a beautiful
homepage there you go so now we have now
we have our first app working something
interesting is that when you're working
on development you could say you can
change this save it refresh and you get
it so when you're doing development
development is actually really useful to
keep that working all the time and
seeing how the what the answer you get
if you do something wrong like breaking
the code that won't compile you will get
your compiler errors on the on the page
really doesn't look that bad in general
just very big but saying yeah something
won't happen there so we can save it
refresh any word together cool so now
what I want to do is I want to write
every single time there's there's a
request to my posts so now I'm gonna say
only posts just leave the past's okay so
for now we don't have anything special
and what I want to what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna cheat and I'm gonna say you
know the post should be should be Jason
I'm gonna define a constant which is a
Jason it's a string constant that
contains all the parts that I want to
send and I'm just gonna write that
instead go so I'm just sending that
constant into the output oops
404 I need to say pass
and I have Jason now this is a rest api
it's technically a rest api it's a very
useless rest api and it has some issues
like what happen if i forget this coma
here well your front end will crash
that's everything that's gonna happen
you're backing Wilden know so okay let's
try to make it a little bit better so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
define a type that matches that that
object so and go you can say type first
is a struct and a structs pretty much
okay class so it has fields and every
fill has a type you can say I have my
UID which is a string my text which is a
string user name which is a string
avatar which is a string and favorite
with the boolean save put it there and I
have to write all of those in capital
letters because and go if you if you
write lowercase it means that that field
or type or whatever is it's not visible
from outside your package so when we're
going to try to encode something into
jason the json encoder will not be able
to see it so i have to put those so now
I'm going to say my posts is actually a
list of posts and just gonna put this
here so she's gonna remove this is
because you you don't really need to
have those names there and go okay and
then words know doesn't work oh you need
those commas there sure there you go
okay so now instead of JSON we actually
have a go object that's a goal value
it's a list of past grinning go and if
we don't change anything what we're
doing is writing that passed directly to
the output so let's see what we get we
get something which is pretty much what
we want X
that it's not Jason but you have all the
data so let's try to make that and code
JSON for real so to do that we're gonna
use the JSON package which is encoding
JSON and go so you can do you can create
a new encoder and when you create a JSON
encoder the only parameter that it
requires is where are you going to
encode those things so what's the output
in this case the output is the same
output as before it's W that's an
encoder and I need to call now encode
and I'm going to encode those posts now
if I do this that already works that's
already Jason right but there's a
problem which is encode returns an error
and I'm not checking it so you go
there's no exceptions you have to handle
those errors yourself so if the air is
no Neil we're going to log an error so
we're gonna say thank coding that fail
so that will actually print it okay so
now we have something that's slightly
more boss and yeah it's the works cool
now imagine that we keep on adding more
and more of this there's things that are
going to be common all the time which is
encoding JSON decoding JSON and then
doing this handle func of my url to
whatever I want so all of these things
if you write your rest of here like this
you're gonna have to write them yourself
and it's going to be boring pretty fast
so instead what we're gonna be using
it's we're gonna be using actually
before that yeah before that before
moving to using cloud endpoints we're
gonna see how to use the data store
instead so right now all the posts are
here right the past should not whoops I
broke something the past should not come
from a
variable they should come from the
database from the data store so let's
use that instead so I'm not going to
change anything here what I'm gonna
change is I'm gonna say okay I want to
create I want to access the data store
end up on App Engine every single time
you try to do something that is
involving other than your instance so
your own memory you have to use a
context and that helps you have the
permissions and also link different
requests together so then you can see
the logs for everything that was done
because of a given request do that we're
gonna import App Engine and create it
create a new context so that's going to
suit App Engine in context of our now we
got it now we have a context next step
is we're gonna do a query and to do that
we're gonna use the datastore to use the
datastore App Engine datastore whoops
and datastore has a new query new query
what it receives is the kind of object
that you're looking to retrieve so
that's pretty much equivalent to the
table name in a relational database so
we're gonna call it all of these are
posts so I'm gonna call that a pasta can
is passed and then what I can do a lot
of things I can add filters so say I
only want the posts from this user I
only one the post with this picture with
no pictures and things things like that
I just want all the posts so I'm gonna
go get all get all gets two parameters
the first one is the context so you
every single time you're doing something
outside of your instance you need that
context so we're gonna pass it the
second one is the destination and the
destination is going to be the list of
posts and to do that actually we're
going to create a list of paths that is
empty so rather than having all the
paths from before just we're gonna
create an empty and use that to retrieve
when look when we go get all that will
return to things it will return all the
keys from all this all of those object
objects and an error and go when you're
right and go you're gonna see there's
errors very often if that fail we're
just gonna log an error so fetch in
fetching posts fell gonna log that error
and return don't do anything else
otherwise I'm going to encode those
posts so that's exactly the same so
that's it now rather than creating our
post from scratch which is we retrieving
those posts from the data store
let's see if that compiles it does not
compile because these is already defined
so I'm not using keys indeed you get a
gopher who was it you get a gopher okay
and did we get something that I cannot
see I have the problem that I don't know
what's happening here
yeah but this should still encode
something though no they're not but they
should still print an empty empty list
let's see see arrow something might have
failed here and so I'm going to display
their here in clothing so let's try it
here we can go to the logs and see that
it's an invalid data type because I'm
passing a list but I want to modify the
list so if you want to modify something
and go you have to pass a pointer so
we have to pass a pointer to the list
that's it that way
the datastore will be able to modify
that list and add all the paths that I
want okay let's try again
cool enter list we don't have anything
there now the next step could be doing
all the all the different end points so
how to add a post how to add the
favorites and so on and the problem is
that if you start doing that again was
what I was saying before you're gonna
have a lot of boilerplate code that is
repeated over and over so instead of
doing that what we're gonna do is we're
gonna solve the front using Cloud
endpoints so with Cloud endpoints what
we need to do is we we need to define a
type that it's gonna be our API that
contains all the endpoints so it's gonna
be list add and set favorite and then
you have to register that so let's see
step by step so here we're going to do
endpoints the handle and now listener
handle listen and handle is that correct
now it's not correct let me cheat for a
second No
okay this is the one and there's the one
I'm working on so this is the import
statement to use go endpoints that's
where the library is and actually if you
get this URL and you go directly to
github you will see the code so that's
pretty useful okay so now I can actually
use know what endpoints let me cheat a
little bit more registers handle HTTP
okay so handle HTTP
and handle HDPE what its gonna do it's
gonna do all the handle thunks that we
were doing before that's gonna be
automated directly from the type that
we're doing so okay so let's create that
type I'm gonna create my type I'm gonna
call it post API which is an empty
struct doesn't have any data inside but
it's going to have methods so we're
going to define the methods list add and
set favorite on that type so now our
list post is going to be the method list
on the type post API and this is how you
define methods in go so now I given a
post API a value of post API
I could call list on that and that good
work now I have to change some more
things I actually get directly a context
so I can remove this thing here and
rather than getting a request and
response I get I get to choose what I do
so you can the simplest one is this it's
just the list it's a method that doesn't
do anything and could fail so it will
return an error but we actually want to
return something more we want to return
a list of posts so to do that there's
one extra thing with that we need to do
which is every so if we return something
or we obtain something it has to be a
pointer to a struct so we need to define
a stroke that contains a list so I'm
gonna call that posts which is a strug
that contains lists that's it okay so
now I can say return posts and an error
to make it a little bit smaller there
you go now I don't need to do this so
I'm gonna start creating my context I'm
gonna go fetch all the posts and then
either need to go the encoding I just
returned a past with the posts that have
oh sorry
I removed a line that I didn't have to
remove that line we still have to have
it that's the list of posts so we're
eating all the posts but now all of
these parts were we're encoding to just
return posts and nayer and instead of
logging those errors you can return
nothing and the error so now we have the
whole code it's just that it's get all
the posts from the data store if that
fail return there
otherwise return the posts end no error
that's everything you need to do almost
now what we have to do is we actually
have to tell endpoints that these the
surface that we want to use so we're
gonna use register service we have to
pass a value of our API so I'm gonna
pass a post a PI a value of it so that's
an empty of post API and then there's
many parameters that I don't remember so
I'm going to go to the commutation so
going joins go dorg okay so the
commutation for endpoints register
service it has the service itself the
name the version description and if it's
default or not cool so the name it's
gonna be called posts the version v1 the
description cost API and is default I'm
gonna say that yes it's default so that
the default version of my
yeah basically now that's it let's try
it and see what happens on this 404
which is normal and I need to do one
more thing so the end points is
something that will X will expose a REST
API and that REST API uses exactly the
same technology as the REST API is that
we use at Google so basically if you
have used before things like cloud
storage or even the data store has a
REST API all of those where CP is are
based on this technology and they're
exposed in a very specific path we have
to make sure that that path is
accessible and to do that what we're
going to do is change our Abdur demo
from what we have before that everything
goes there we actually have to say this
path and SPI is actually a service point
interface which is I think technical
name for Cloud endpoints so basically
we're saying ok so if go to if it goes
here it's handled by Cloud endpoints ok
so now why did we do this so now if I go
to underscore aah API Explorer I get
this really cool thing which is my API
Explorer and I can explore the API that
I just wrote I can say that there's a
method pass to list and I can call it
and see that it returns absolutely
nothing now this at least for me this is
really cool this that this allows you to
test really easily and this is exactly
the same technique that so this is based
on the same technique that generates a
code and so on so ok now we have
something that works pretty well let's
add the add method so
funk post API and see and puts that
context error okay let's think about
this for a minute what's what's the
parameters that we need in the request
when we want to add a request well we
need pretty much all of this but
actually there's two things that we
don't need so I'm gonna create a new
type that I'm gonna call add request the
UID you don't get to choose that that's
the the data store we'll choose that for
you
so you don't get to choose that and you
don't get to choose if your post is
favored or not that's true up to others
to decide so we move that you so we're
gonna say that the request that we get
is an ADD request and it will return an
actual post and an error so the past
containing the UID and so on so this
will be the actual the final post so
let's do this now the cool thing is that
this these already handles the decoding
from Jason to our type to the type of
that which is defined so we don't have
to care about that if the URL if the
post if the object that we receive
doesn't match the description of this
object within D what they will get a
status it will get an error there will
be something like pad request which I
don't remember what memories but there's
a state status for them okay so we have
a request
cool what do we do with it well I'm
going to create a new post so T it's
going to be a post that's going to have
text it's gonna be auto text username
it's gonna be our dot user name and
avatar it's going to be our avatar cool
and I'm going to save that into a
datastore so to save it I'm gonna use
the datastore that put input have three
parameters the first one is the context
again every single time you do something
outside of the instance there's a
context then there's a key and what's
the key that we want to give to this
note well we don't know and this is a
there's a way of creating those keys
which is new incomplete key when you
create an incomplete key basically
you're saying I know the kind I know
these are past but I don't know they
actually did you choose it
so again context the kind we said it was
past and the parent is if you have
ancestors and that's a more advanced
topic that going on we won't talk about
today so I'm gonna go with new there's
no ancestors we're gonna use that key
and then the source is going to be our
pointer to P so you're going to say P
into the datastore and that returns a
new key and an error so that key is
actually the new key that actually
contains all the data if the error is no
nil then we're going to return nil
because we then create a new task and an
error so you can create a new error
saying put toast and I'm hunting with
that question again please yes I'm so I
if you don't do that if you ignore that
error then your code will have this in
here and this is basically saying I know
there's an error but I don't care about
it and the effect of that is that if
there's an error you won't do anything
about it
so you will continue with the rest of
your code so you have to Ingo you have
to write this kind of code where you
check if something failed every single
time
now this might seem like something
boring
or exhausting at the beginning but the
cool thing is that you will not forget
any error so you will get to code that
is robust way faster than with the
exception code I still write a lot of
Python and with Python I have that issue
with Python very often during my tests
or even once it's deployed I realized
that there's some some case that I
didn't think about and there's an
exception and probably it will just
catch all the exceptions and just say
oops with go you actually forced to
think about the errors from the
beginning so yeah so now if that
actually worked we actually got our new
a new task I'm just going to return the
task and so I I said that the part of
the task the past sorry I'm going to
return the past which is a pointer and
no no cool so let's see if that works
no so I will show how to do that in a
minute okay so and I will refresh this
now I have list and add so let's write
to add so I'm gonna say the username is
francisc the text is Cloud endpoints
rules and avatar it's gonna be whatever
image we had before going go for logo
this one here this time oh whatever
so the image cool so we're gonna use
that one execute and the response was
200 avatar favorite text UID is empty in
it
so the UID is not set and we have a
username cool so how do we do this well
actually we have to get the key that we
got and put it into the into the object
itself so let's do that
so everything we need to do is P the UID
equals
and now you could do something like key
Dodd encode string so this will actually
return a string right so you basically
encoding that key which has a lot of
information into something that it's
easy to send through H DHCP so you will
be able to use it from your web pages
and so on but there's a gonna and this
should work by the way let's try it so
if I run exactly same thing now it works
and I get this this object here now
there's a better way of doing this which
is in go there's the typing system that
we have is similar to duck typing it's
not that typing but it's similar and
there's a thing that you can do which is
ask if a type satisfies if a value
satisfies an interface and there's an
interface that it's basically saying do
you have a special way of encoding to
JSON which is a JSON encoder actually so
and the data store key it's actually one
of those so what we can do is we can say
this is a pointer to datastore dot key
this is a datastore key and now I can
just set it there the cool thing this
won't change much so this will still
work the cool thing is that now that the
coding of that will also work so if I
get a update a key and encoded key
directly it would just decode it to my
actual pointer to datastore ducky so I
can use it dragon cool so let's see if
our list C works
no datastore cannot field UID that
mismatch yes
so the problem is that if you change the
values of the data store like we have we
have now we've stored strings and we're
trying to decode them to keys and that
doesn't really work so we need to config
there's a way of removing the data store
so we can start from scratch download
data no
clear now do you remember this no thank
you
so oh I think it's clean not clear see
no so let's see probably actually let me
see yeah there's a local data store
hello because I'm stupid it's not it's
dev appserver that's a local thing
so that's dev appserver clear wow that's
bad
clean No Oh grab clear
oh that's clear okay that makes sense
let me just find it clear data store
clear everybody sees it except for me
that's not clear data store I got it
okay so now I can run dev app server /
clear datastore dot na step zero and
that's pretty much the same thing except
that it fails o equals yes cool so this
is actually the whole thing we used to
use with go we don't use it anymore but
there's some things that we have an app
like this thing yet go so now I'm just
gonna go to my go up as before so this
basically just removed everything from
the data store so if I execute the list
just returns an empty list if I click it
add avatar no yeah okay that whatever
so now it's datastore datastore clearly
director and that's it works because
we're not actually checking that that's
anything about it
and we're getting the UAV that matches
what we expect and our list if you
execute it we get that list cool with
nil so what's happening here well the
thing is that we we didn't store that
key right so in our code when we stored
the post in the data store we didn't
store the key because we didn't have it
so there's two options here one is well
I'm just going to store it so I'm gonna
store it get the key and story again
which is not a very good idea the other
option is not to store the the object
completely don't don't store the key in
the datastore now to do that then what I
need to do is I need to use the keys
that I received here so basically now
when I get all the posts and the keys
I'm gonna go and put the pub every
single key in every single past so for I
key range keys
first off I died you idea what that you
I I'm doing some outposts of I your idea
equals key and now I will run it again
that should work there you go
now we have it now there is one more
thing that we can do which is we can
actually say oh but I don't want to
store the data key at all and to do that
but we're gonna use it's something that
it's called the field tags so it's just
a string and you can say the data store
name for this object is - and that means
don't store this now the next thing
we're going to do is whoops
I broke the thing data store why did it
break let's see here
no didn't break anything yet let's
refresh cute bad request why bad request
cannot load filled your ID hello because
it actually stored that field on the
data store and now it said that that
field doesn't exist in this truck
because we just added the tag saying
don't store this so the datastore
complains
so the solution we already know that one
it's just clearly the data stored and
starting again
so let's write again execute it works
and if we this is the last time I'm
gonna create a past I swear well not
gonna swear because prolly gonna create
one more letter so it's mister clear
data store again I'll miss clear so that
created it we're gonna go to list really
cute it and now posts is in low in
uppercase avatar is an uppercase
favorite is in uppercase u it is an
uppercase and so on and if you write
JavaScript or JSON or anything you know
that in JSON all the fields are in
lowercase
how do we fix that well using exactly
the same technique as we use with the
data store so we're gonna say the JSON
name for this is UID the JSON name for
this is text the JSON name for this is
username and Jason name for this is
avatar and the JSON name for this is
favorite I see there's a pie here okay
like I see there the type of asset that
a user name favorite text just day it's
that good yeah that looks good okay so
now we're going to execute that again
and now we have all the names as we one
are we missing pasts so past it's going
to be called Jason
Faust's cool
see that cool it works now we're going
to write the the last part which is set
favorite and not say favorite just print
interesting because when we need to do
is we're gonna get you ID so the the
idea of the test that we want to change
and the value of the boolean that we
want to send for favorite so true or
false and what we need to do is we need
to fetch that post change it and store
it again now there's a problem with that
which is what happens in the meanwhile
someone fetch that spots change the name
and puts it back and then in the main
well we save it afterwards that's a
pretty much a data race so we good we
could actually have problems with the
data and not being consistent so a way
of the way of solving that is using I
forgot the word transactions so we're
going to use a transaction we're gonna
create a transaction in the and inside
of that transaction we're gonna fetch
the past change it and put it back and
that's one single transaction if we say
that that failed at some point when
we're saving or whatever it will not
change anything or if some if the object
that we got changed while we were doing
our transaction that transaction will
also fail okay so let's write that going
to create a new endpoint post API and
I'm gonna call it safe favorite and it
gets endpoints dot context and we'll
return an error and I'm gonna call that
say favorite request that's a pretty
long name but whatever gonna define that
struct and now what do we need in here
well we need the UID so that's the data
store key which we call actually with
the need to net rename it when we're
decoding the J's
package will decode also if even though
the case that's a match so you can't
forget about that that that works
automatically and then we also needed
favorite which is a boolean okay so
let's write it as we did before pretty
much so we're gonna get so data stored
get get a context a key and the
destination so the destination is going
to be post I'm gonna call it post okay
whatever and I'm going to say story
there now what is the key the key is
simply are that UID
that's the UID that we're getting and we
don't have to care about the coding in
or anything because that's Cloud
endpoints gonna do that for you that
will return something an error if that
error is not nil then something bad
happened so we could do different things
I'm not gonna explain this but in with
Cloud endpoints you can actually handle
different errors like not found so in
this case could be a good example to say
not found if that's actually not found
you can see it but I'm just gonna return
a internal server error 500 which is the
default so there F get post felt with
that message otherwise we actually get
now we got the post instead of the past
so post favorite equals our favorite and
then we're gonna save it so to save it
data store that put the key it's the
same one
ru ID and the source is the same one
past that will return a key that we
don't care about this time in an error
if the air is not nil then we're gonna
return an error saying save past or
update past maybe update past that fail
with that message and otherwise we're
gonna return now and that's all the code
now where's the transaction now where we
didn't use it yet so to use it for
section the way you do it is you use
data store run in transaction and rank
transaction has three parameters the
first one a context again you're gonna
get used to using context the second one
is a function it's actually a function
that given an app engine context returns
an error which turns out to be exactly
this and then the options that we have
and look we're not going to be using any
options did I do something wrong here
probably this is not saving correctly
[ __ ] App Engine context or tones in here
hmm yeah but this is not saving
correctly so let's see undefined App
Engine app engine oh now it worked now
it actually moved it that's a good thing
with when you're doing going ports and
go fund and so on if your code is not
formatting every single time you saved
you know that there's something wrong we
sublime text to the error message is
very well hidden so it's better to go to
the logs and see why it fail okay so and
that that indeed returns an error so I'm
just gonna return put it on there that's
it sublime text to these this software
that I'm using these version two of
sublime yeah that's the one I have a
license for so that's one I'm using so
okay let's see if that works let's
refresh that's bad
no need variables on the left side of
that line 81
there's no error was already defined
there so you can you don't need to
redefine it refresh okay so the possibly
I now have has the three methods that we
want to use at least and set favorite
and set favorite is ugly I want that F
to be capital letters so we're gonna see
how to change that
so that's right so I'm gonna get that
one I'm gonna get the key and then I'm
gonna go back go to set favorite what
did you do the property and for the UID
I'm gonna set that your idea I just
copied from the other one
I'm favorite and gonna say it's true I'm
gonna execute it and that returns 204
okay okay if we go back and we go to the
list we will see that now favorites
isn't it true cool so we have our whole
API I'm just gonna change one thing
which is I want I once ate favorite to
actually be named set favorite with the
capital F because I like to be to have
code that is readable to do that to do
that kind of things you actually have an
API and an error that I should have
handled by the way and I forgot so if
the error is not nil here that's that
way bad if you're not able to register
your API you cannot do much so I'm just
gonna lock fatal that's gonna take it
down and otherwise API has a method
which I don't remember
let's go to the commutation again so go
dot org endpoints I think it's by name
something method by name so method by
name given a name it returns a service
service method so we're going to do that
so service by name
said favorite that's the name that we
had initially so the name of the method
and that's going to return a method and
service method we have that's not the
good men method by name that returns
service Meza sir method service method
hmm that's wrong service uh no info
sorry
okay so service method hasn't Fung a
method that's hard to say
service method has a method that returns
a service info and that's the one we're
gonna use so info info and that has some
info and the method info and Method info
has a lot of things we're just gonna
change the name so name the one that it
will generate the JavaScript where the
name for the JavaScript generated
JavaScript so I'm gonna say in for the
name equals set favorite let's see if
that word so if i refresh
method by name yeah that's that's why
not service my name method by name thank
you refresh cool and now you can see
it's a favorite so you can actually
determine what kind of code you want to
generate and this is really useful
because the next step that I did was I
got all of this code and I so how many
of you have gone through the polymer
tutorial okay so basically I got the
polymer tutorial and there's one thing
which is called as the thing it's called
note service or post service under that
what I did was just to change just that
file so I'm gonna show you that file now
so the front end has a bunch of things
and one of the elements is this bus
service and now what I'm saying here is
I'm using an element which it's the
Google API loader and the Google API
loader and giving it the idea of my app
and the name of the API and the version
that I want to load now when that's
loaded it will actually call it will
actually fire an event and I will serve
that I will save that API and from that
from now on the only thing you need to
do is oh if you want to get the post
call the method cat posts if you want to
add the post call the method at posts
with the post that you just received and
if you want to set favorite this is how
you do it and that's everything you need
to do that's all the this all the glue
that you have between the front end and
the back end
it's auto-generated completely and if
you want to do similar thing for for an
Android AP and Android app you can have
the same things you get a can get some
code that is auto-generated completely
and you will be able to call it now the
good thing with this is that if you
change something in your code you don't
have to go and change all the so
depending on what you're changing if
you're changing a type for instance
probably your code will keep on will
keep on working if you add some new
methods if you will just get more
methods and your code will
break so it's a very good way of
maintaining a single codebase that
generates all the all the end points for
your different apps so just to try that
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
serve both the step zero and the front
end from sorry so when you do that you
actually have steady demo and found out
the demo so now I'm serving both the
front end and the back end and let's see
if that works so now you're gonna see
that there's 80 80 80 81 and yeah that's
it 80 80 and 80 81 so I'm actually
missing so I have the front end on the
back end but I need one more file which
is The Dispatch the demo which is here
the spaetzle llamo what it says it says
if that contains the underscore aah SPI
that's for the default which is the back
end otherwise send it to the front end
and that's all the HTML CSS and so on so
now this is basically what it says where
to send the request to what module you
should send it so I'm gonna add that so
I'm going to add dispatch demo we will
see that now it started 8080 for the
dispatcher 80 81 for the default and 80
82 for the front end so what happens if
we go to 8080 we will see wow that's big
so we will see this feels like cheating
why am I getting this oh I know so I'm
actually cheating there so the prong
here is that the front end and the post
service so you want to make sure that in
development mode your front is actually
using the API that you're back in it's
exposing not the one that is exposed on
the on the production one so the way to
do it is just saying this is the route
that you should use
and dip so let's try it again
API sounds better though okay so let's
try localhost:8080 and there's nothing
coming sad what happened let's see the
error it's a bad request for getting
he's our backing down or something
now that should just work now of course
the demo of the demo for which is the
cool part will not work localhost:8080
80 82
sorry 80 81 now there's something
something wrong
let me see that's a very small message
let me actually see what I have in HTTP
HTTPS now HTTPS / localhost 8080 I think
that's how it's supposed to be oh no
it's not this one so one second please
let's see the documentation for that
Google API dying loader so Google API
loader no not that one polymer
a Google sign-in Google API volley where
this one here the documentation is here
okay it's supposed to be good why it's
API it's your fault
it was API huh it's actually your fault
Wow
with hepi not GPS Wow shame on you okay
and did it work no I'm the fan it's not
a function I love to escape sometimes
cool so I broke something another I
don't know what exactly but I'm a works
on production right so
so that should be enough let me let me
try to find the air Plus service 23 for
service 23 get past oh the names aren't
a good so we have get past and actually
we call the list so let's change that
this feels like it's actually preferred
it's not again so let's go to change
just gonna copy so the method that we
call list it's actually get posts and
the method we call add I think it's at
post let's see that the method add
passed yeah so we're gonna do that to
add at post let's refresh yes yay
basically really sorry
cool well that image is kinda kind of
wrong but and now the good thing is that
you can keep on working with the rest so
full bar and now we're gonna actually
use an image so victory image whatever
that is yeah that sounds like something
I can use right there yes
so yeah so this is how to build a modern
web app the rest of the code is it's
gonna be on github soon but that's
actually not complicated it's well if
you know how to use polymer basically
but I think that this is a pretty good
demonstration on how to build an app
from scratch it's pretty simple the code
is very simple to understand and the
good thing is that if you had millions
of users going to this Apple of a sudden
it could just scale and work